stellen sie sich vor dass sie nach
jahrelanger kräfte zu einer ausbildung
in etlichen berufsjahren plötzlich nicht
mehr arbeiten dürfen sie schauen
hektischen die medien wie jetzt der
aktuelle stand ist wie lange dürfen sie
im beruf noch ausüben so ergeht es in
deutschland nicht nur den pflegern die
einrichtungs bezogen im pflicht sind
seit mitte märz vor dass alle
beschäftigten etwa in krankenhäusern
pflegeheimen und arztpraxen eine
doppelte impfung gegen coop 19 vorweisen
müssen am ersten oktober wird die
regelung auf drei impfungen verschärft
liegt ein mitarbeiter dem gesundheitsamt
kein entsprechenden nachweis vor kann
ein betretungsverbot verhängt werden das
ist ehrlich gesagt nichts anderes als
ein arbeitsverbot die einrichtungs
bezogen impfpflicht ist meiner meinung
nach nicht solidarisch sondern asozial
und muss weg ich habe hier ein politiker
am tisch der hat dafür gestimmt und mich
interessieren jetzt erstmal die
beweggründe für die entscheidung damals
mein gewissen hat mich einfach geleitet
und gesagt jawohl ich muss wohl gruppen
einfach schützen den krankenhäusern und
deswegen habe ich diese entscheidung
getroffen falls vollen bewusstsein aber
ich war ja keine züge